we've been talking about the law of
demand and how if we hold all else equal
a change in price if price goes up the
quantity demanded goes down and if price
goes down the quantity demanded goes up
so if you hold all else equal ceteris
paribus we are just moving along this
curve depending on what price but we
started talking about is what happens
when you change some of those things
that we've been holding equal how does
that change demand in the last video we
talked about the price of related goods
price of related goods and if the price
of related goods change both complements
and substitutes how that might change
the in that how that might increase or
decrease demand the entire curve not
just one particular scenario now let's
talk about let's talk about another one
of those factors that we've been holding
constant and think about how that would
change demand the entire curve if we
were to change that and that's that's
expectations of future prices i'll do
that in the screen so expectations
expectations
of future prices of future
future prices
so let's say that let's talk about a
first scenario right over here where
let's say that this curve people didn't
expect prices to change for my ebook and
now all of a sudden people expect that
there's a change in expectation now all
of a sudden they expect the prices to go
up going forward
so now
now
now expect
expect the future price
the future price
to
go
up what's going to happen if you expect
the future price to go up and the the
good or the product in question is
something that you can store well and
depending on how much you expect it to
go up you're probably more likely to buy
it now buy it before the price goes up
so regardless of what point on this
curve we're at regardless of the price
point at any one of those price points
people now because they want to instead
of buying it later they want to buy it
now they are more the current demand
will go up at any of these price points
so at two dollars more people will want
to buy it because they think it's going
to go up at four dollars more people
want to buy it because i think it's
going to go up at any of these price
points because now there's an ex
the expectations have gone from being
neutral to now expecting prices to go up
it will shift the entire curve to the
right so this will shift the entire
curve to the right so this right over
here is scenario one and depends how
much this changes to say how much this
shifts to the right this is just the
general idea this is gener scenario one
and the shifting of the entire curve you
could say they increased demand so this
is literally demand increasing
demand
demand increased and when we talk about
demand remember and i'm you're probably
tired of me saying this i'm not talking
about a particular quantity i'm talking
about the entire curve shifting to the
right because people expect future
prices to go up so the current demand
went up the current demand curve shifted
to the right and now we can just take
the other side of that imagine what
happens in scenario two
before people were neutral that was our
curve right there they didn't have any
opinion about whether future prices were
going to go up or down or maybe they
just assumed they were going to stay the
same and now they expect future prices
to go down
now
expect
future prices
to
go down and this is something that
happens in consumer electronics all the
time you see whenever you buy a laptop
or any type of electronics device you we
now assume that the prices will go down
now what we're talking about is a change
in expectations so you're going from
neutrality or let's say you're going
from you expect them to go down but now
you expect them to go down even faster
and if all of a sudden you expect them
to go down even faster you're even less
likely to buy them now so if you expect
if before you thought prices were going
to be roughly costed and now you expect
them to go down
now you're going to say well hey at any
given price point why don't i just hold
off a little bit and and and wait a
little bit so it's going to lower demand
so in this scenario
the whole curve will shift to the left
at any given price point the quantity
demanded will go down at any point on
that curve and so the entire demand
curve will be shifted to the left so
because of scenario 2 demand
demand
was decreased
demand was decreased